the left cheers is DOJ and FBI officials
are exposed for trying to subvert our
republic and overturn a presidential
election then they cheer as a vicious
anti-semite and terrorist apologist
smears an American patriot before a
congressional committee finally love and
marriage from st. Valentine to his ease
Ansari and of course the mailbag I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
happy Valentine's Day baby oh we've got
a lot to talk about today but first I
want you to feel like when you're with
me on this romantic holiday that you
feel safe and secure and the best way to
feel safe and secure is to secure your
home with a ring doorbell rings mission
is to make neighborhoods safer you might
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor you'll
get an alert and be able to see hear and
speak to them all from your phone you
could be in the living room in the
bedroom on a beach in Boca at the office
wherever you are you can communicate
with whoever's at your home that is
thanks to the HD video and two-way audio
features on ring devices they are super
cool I love mine ring makes me feel much
more secure I've actually given a ring
as a just a personal gift to friends
it is super sleek it is so simple it's
such a good way not only to secure your
home but also to actually be able to
communicate with delivery men people are
going to come over to work you just feel
like you've got eyes on and in your home
at all times as a listener you have a
special offer on a ring starter kit
available right now with a video
doorbell and motion-activated floodlight
cam the store kit has everything you
need to start building a ring of
security around your home just go to
ring.com slash knowles KO wles that's
ring.com slash knowles KO wles
big news coming out today Andrew McCabe
the disgraced FBI official the guy who
we knew was trying to subvert the 2016
election we saw those text messages
where he was texting
Lisa Paige that was his lover even
though he was married at the time
Lisa Paige's colleague and lover saying
that they would have an insurance policy
in case Donald Trump managed to get
elected in case those deplorable
American people elected the presidential
candidate of their choice he would try
to use the power of the state to undo
that presidential election and now
Andrew McCabe is making public
statements he went on 60 minutes he's
written a book and this guy epitomizes
totally embodies what the
feared about a large overbearing
government this guy the framers of our
constitution designed our constitutional
republic in such a way as to thwart the
ambitions of petty tyrants like Andrew
McCabe and here he is still defending
himself and here the left is still
cheering him on cheering on
unaccountable bureaucratic power to
subvert how the American people want to
govern themselves here is how he opens
up the interview has not come out yet on
60 minutes
but they've released some early clips uh
but we're never waiting till Sunday for
the whole thing I was speaking to the
man who had just run for the presidency
and it she and and won the election for
the presidency and who might have done
so with the aid of the government of
Russia
our most formidable adversary on the
world stage and that was something that
troubled me greatly
Andrew McCabe's fantasies troubled him
greatly what troubles me greatly is his
presumptuousness his his conceited
notion that he not only knows better
than the American people who should
govern this country but that it is it is
up to him he has the right he has the
ability to go in and overrule the entire
American people it's that kind of
radicalism that is so despicable this
man obviously should never have been
permitted in in public service he
certainly should be prosecuted for what
amounts to treason that is what this guy
took part in treason against his own
government an enemy a domestic enemy of
the United States there's no other way
to describe him but listen to all the
fantasies here he said I I was talking
to the man who was just elected
President of the United States and he
might have done so he might have done so
with the help of the Russian government
is there any evidence that he had the
help of the Russian government do you
have because we've had investigations
now for two years
there's no evidence whatsoever turned up
nothing actually the Senate Intelligence
Committee just had its own investigation
into Russian collusion
the Trump campaign working with Russia
they came up with nothing not only the
Republicans on the committee say they
came up with nothing the Democrats too
but they're a even MSNBC reported this
they said they talked to Democrats
sources on the committee they said yep
came up with nothing
so that's that is just a fantasy of
Andrew McCabe either it's a fantasy or
he's lying and we know he's a liar
we know he has misled investigators we
know that he has lied that's why he was
fired in absolute disgrace so he's
probably just lying but then he goes on
he says Russia is our number-one
adversary it's our most it's our biggest
most threatening adversary no it's not
China is our biggest adversary the way I
by the way the way I know this is that
Republicans and Democrats agree on this
conservatives and leftists agree on this
remember Mitt Romney who's mostly wrong
about everything
Mitt Romney came out and said Russia's
our number one geopolitical foe and
Obama made fun of him during a national
debate said uh Governor Romney the 80s
called they want their foreign policy
back Cold War's over okay actually
you're right the Cold War is over
doesn't mean the Russians love us now
there's still an adversary but the far
greater threat comes from China just in
terms of manpower in terms of the
military in terms of stealing our
intellectual property in terms of
encroaching on our interests in the
South China Sea and encroaching on our
allies in the South China Sea what do
you fear do you fear a war coming from
Russia or from China of course this has
been the the growing view since the end
of the Cold War that the next great
adversary we have is China not Russia
but Andy McCabe needs to cover up his
crimes and his treason so he has to
harken back and say this is our number
one adversary no evidence of that
whatsoever then he gets to the heart of
his crimes I was very concerned that I
was able to put the Russia case on
absolutely solid ground in an indelible
fashion that were I removed quickly or
reassigned or fired that the case could
not be closed or vanish in the night
without a trace I wanted to make sure
that our case was on solid ground and if
somebody came in behind me and closed it
and tried to walk away from it they
would
not be able to do that without creating
a record of why they'd made that
decision I Andrew McCabe a petty tyrant
bureaucrat wanted to make sure that
before I was fired in disgrace for for
misleading investigators for lying for
total corruption in my job in my job in
which I have been given the public trust
before I was fired in disgrace I would
be able to wield the instruments of the
bureaucracy in such a way that the duly
elected representatives of the American
people were thwarted in following and
carrying out the plans of the American
people that's what I wanted to do I
wanted to make sure that I a crook a
corrupt bureaucrat could you abuse my
position in such a way as to thwart the
government of the American people and
our constitutional republic what there
are many things that I could call that
man that I probably shouldn't in in
polite company
so what did he do and the room Andrew
McCabe ordered the obstruction and
counterintelligence probes why did he do
it because Donald Trump fired his pal
James Comey so everyone was calling on
James Comey to be fired
Democrats and Republicans Chuck Schumer
and Donald Trump Donald Trump actually
fired James Comey in retaliation for the
duly elected president firing the FBI
director totally his right totally is
broad enough to do Andrew McCabe a
corrupt bureaucrat decided to retaliate
by miring the duly elected president in
ridiculous absurd investigations for as
long as he possibly could he tried to
use executive authority to subvert the
Republic and ultimately to what to
remove the President of the United
States from office so what's coming out
we don't have the full interview yet is
that according to Andrew McCabe there
were talks at the DOJ and the FBI about
coming together picking off a few of the
cabinet members and using the power of
what is called the deep state the
bureaucracy to force the president out
there were actual open conversations
among DOJ and FBI officials about a coup
d'etat overthrowing
the government a billion from within an
insurrection to undo a presidential
election because Andrew McCabe some
idiot crook knows better than the
American people how to govern the
country according to Andrew McCabe the
Deputy Attorney General was apparently
rod Rosenstein he was apparently willing
to wear a wire
in in his conversations with the
president now rod Rosenstein in the DOJ
just released a statement today refuting
this and and the defense seems to be
that rod Rosen Stein was joking it was a
sarcastic remark that he would wear a
wire Andrew McCabe came back and said
absolutely was not sarcastic it was said
multiple times quite seriously it was so
serious that McCabe had DOJ and FBI
lawyers looking into whether that would
be legal to have the Deputy Attorney
General wearing a wire bugging his
conversations with the President of the
United States to try to undo the
election so why did McCabe get fired
McCabe got fired because the IG report
found that he misled investigators about
the FBI investigation into the Clinton
Foundation he misled investigators about
leaking Andrew McCabe directed people to
leak at the FBI and he he misled
investigators about this and he was
fired
obviously in disgrace Andrew McCabe it's
worth pointing out also is not some
disinterested above it all American
patriot I don't have a party country
above party no no no he is a Democrat
hack he is a well entrenched Democrat
hack but a Democrat hack none the less
his wife is a Democrat politician his
wife ran for Virginia state Senate and
failed but his wife when she ran for a
Virginia State Senate took a donation
from Terry McAuliffe who is a high
placed Clinton supporter and former
governor of Virginia so you now have
this total corruption you have a
situation in which Hillary Clinton
Donald Trump are running against each
other for the presidency you've got a
guy high placed at the FBI whose wife is
running for state Senate from Virginia
the Clinton campaign a well placed
person within the Clinton
campaign makes a donation to McCabe's
wife all these people know each other do
you think he made that donation out of
the goodness of his heart do you think
he made it because I really believe in
mrs. McCabe or was there something more
nefarious going on or even if it wasn't
nefarious maybe it was just that totally
bland political corruption you scratch
my back I scratch your back come on man
you've been in DC a long time you know
how the game is played what is it either
way what a crook and either way what
treason what treason to try to undo a
presidential election through a coup
d'etat this is what the framers were
protecting against this is why they
dispersed power throughout the
government and not just throughout the
federal government but throughout all of
our governments local state and federal
is to thwart petty tyrants like this
crook now the question is was this
Russia investigation legitimate or was
it a politically motivated witch-hunt
we'll get to in a second but first you
know how much I love purple mattress you
know ah this week it's been kind of a
long week a lot of travel haven't had a
lot of chance to sleep last night I'm
finally gonna get a full night's sleep
in my purple mattress I lay down in my
mattress I was asleep before my head hit
the pillow this mattress is the most
comfortable mattress I've ever slept on
it's not quite a memory foam it's not
quite an innerspring it's this new
technology it was developed by rocket
scientists it sleeps both soft and firm
at the same time
whatever you think you say oh I don't
have a lot of money Oh - money's a
little tight right now always invest in
the things that connect you to the
ground always invest in things where you
spend a lot of time you know I'd like to
get 21 or 23 hours of sleep per day just
invest in it you're not gonna miss the
extra hundred bucks or whatever you're
gonna pay it this is an incredible
night's sleep check it out right now
they'll give you a hundred on risk free
trial if you're not fully satisfied you
can return your mattress for a full
refund back by 10-year warranty free
shipping and returns free and home set
up and mattress removal you're gonna
love purple right now my listeners will
get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just text Kofi facio
VF
EFE two four seven four seven four seven
the only way to get this free pillow is
to text qoph FAC o v fe f AE two four
seven four seven four seven CoV f EF e
four seven four seven four seven message
and data rights rates rather may apply
so was the russia investigation
legitimate or was it a politically
motivated witch-hunt to undo a
presidential election all of the
evidence points to the latter you've got
this hack democrat operative working in
the FBI he's I know I know that we're
using his wife as evidence that he's a
Democrat operative we're using the
pay-to-play that's going on throughout
all of these campaigns but we should
point out he's also cheating on his wife
with his colleague Lisa page and he's
texting Lisa page and saying there will
be an insurance policy we won't let
Trump win we won't let this happen
mm-hmm on the brave white knight so he
then goes on and actually does all the
things he tells Lisa page he's going to
do he sets up his retaliation for the
firing of Comey these investigations he
sets them up in such a way that they're
very difficult to dislodge two years of
investigations no evidence of any
illegalities Trump and the Russia
campaign's zero evidence the networks
according to News Buster's have spent
twenty two hundred and two minutes
covering the Russia scandal read non
traversée do you know how many minutes
they've spent on Senate collusion under
rather on the Senate collusion report
the one that just came out bipartisan
report or it's about to come out but
they've just released some details of it
she was no evidence whatsoever both
sides of the aisle say that they've
spent zero minutes covering that ABC it
be the closest that they've come is ABC
George Stephanopoulos a Clinton
operative the actual top Clinton
communication operative head of the war
room George Stephanopoulos who pretends
to be a journalist on ABC comes out and
he says well the report it's
inconclusive the report we don't know
there's a war of words is no war of
words just look to their credit MSNBC
actually covered this story fairly they
I guess they had accidentally one real
reporter walked into the room and gave
his report on what's happening but of
the
actual networks ABC NBC CBS the main
Network News it goes out has huge
coverage in the United States they won't
cover it this is the closest they come
to covering it look at the difference
between how George Stephanopoulos a
Clinton operative covers this versus how
MSNBC in their brief moment of real
reporting covered the actual story
Republican and Democratic leaders to the
Senate Intelligence Committee at odds
over the conclusion of their
investigation the heads of the Senate
Intelligence Committee have been working
together but this is a significant
disagreement yo George for a committee
here that has managed to so far
conducted bipartisan investigation this
is now a rare public rift the Republican
Chairman Richard burr says that as of
now they have found no factual evidence
of collusion but he notes that their
investigation is not yet complete but
the top Democrat on the committee
Senator Mark Warner tells us that he
respectfully disagrees that he's not
ready to draw any conclusions since
their probe is still ongoing our bottom
line for this story is that after two
years 200 interviews 300,000 documents
the Senate Intelligence Committee both
Republicans and Democrats are telling us
that they do not have direct evidence
proving a conspiracy between the Trump
campaign and Russia which is after all
the main question they set out to answer
there it is Democrats and Republicans
they all agree but George Stephanopoulos
so so desperate I should point out by
the way I misspoke earlier I was
conflating all of my corrupt crooked FBI
and DOJ officials Andy McCabe is not the
one who was cheating with Lisa Paige
that was Peter struck now they're all in
the same investigations they're all
trying to thwart the duly elected
president so I'll excuse myself for
being confused but Andy McCabe is
married to a Democrat politician and was
accepting bribes I'm sorry of accepting
campaign donations from Clinton
affiliated Democrat politicians Peter
struck working with Andy McCabe is the
one that was cheating on his wife and
also saying that he would undo the
presidential election easy to conflate
the two I put deeply apologize I deeply
personally apologize to Andrew McCabe a
treasonous corrupt hack petty tyrant I
shouldn't have suggested that he cheated
on his
wife like his colleague did who was also
trying to overturn the presidential
election they are very different
corrupt treasonous Democrat hacks I'm
sorry I apologize this is a full
unqualified apology to these traitors to
our country who should probably be
behind bars that's the way is being
covered by the news MSNBC you have to
give them credit every once in a while I
give them credit you know and I don't
know maybe it's because maybe it's
because I'm having a little influence on
the network I mean I think you know when
I take these glasses off up with them on
I'm just saying you've never seen me and
a certain MSNBC host in the same room at
the same time I don't know I don't want
to take credit for it but MSNBC actually
did a pretty good job here now
the other big story that came out
yesterday is representative Ilan Omar
Ilan Omar the Somali American Congress
woman she is affiliated with Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes and Rasheeda Talib she's a
vicious anti-semite she came out and oh
she's also defended terrorists in public
discourse she came out and viciously
attacked Elliott Abrams who's a former
Reagan administration official an
American patriot who has been wrongly
smeared by Democrats he's been wrongly
called a war criminal he is not we'll
explain that in a second here is how
this woman goes and speaks to an
American patriot like Elliott Elliott
Abrams mr. Adams
in 1991 you pleaded guilty to two counts
of withholding information from Congress
regarding your involvement in the
iran-contra affair for which you were
later pardoned by President George HW
Bush I fail to understand why members of
this committee or the American people
should find any testimony that you give
today to be truthful if I can respond to
that
it wasn't a question I'm on that was not
that was not a question that was my I
reserve the right to my time it is not
it is not right that was not a question
he can attack on February 8th who is not
permitted to reply that that was not a
question thank you for your
participation
representative Omar seems to
misunderstand our system of government
here we have a deliberative system of
government we have a constitutional
republic in this country what we are
supposed to have is civil discourse and
debate and what that means is that you
are discouraged from demagoguing
assassinating the character wrongly and
stupidly and with great moral idiocy I
should point out demagoguing when you
are speaking to somebody it's perfectly
fine to land a heart attack it's
perfectly fine to throw a punch it is
generally in this country preferred that
one is given the opportunity to respond
as la neighbours pointed out he said
what you're doing is wrong this is wrong
what you're doing and he's absolutely
right she seems to be unfamiliar with
that maybe because she's a freshman
congresswoman who has entered in
probably the most ignorant congressional
class in American history which is
really saying something by the way she
goes on leader said that the u.s. policy
in El Salvador was a fabulous
achievement yes or no do you still think
so from the day that President Duarte
was elected in a free election to this
day El Salvador has been a democracy
that's a fabulous achievement that is a
fabulous achievement Elliott Abrams was
influential in Latin American policy
under President Reagan and this is one
of these areas where the left is
constantly unfairly assailing
conservatives because they were very
very upset than in the 1980's the Reagan
administration stopped the spread of the
poison of communism in Latin America
they were cheering on the spread of
communism they were praying they were
well I don't know if they pray they were
hoping that in Latin America the poison
of communism would spread the misery the
the untold destruction that communism
brings with it they were really hoping
that that would spread and instead the
Reagan administration thanks in part to
people like Elliott Abrams stopped that
spread forted that spread and Ilan Omar
is very upset by this and she goes on
this was the silliest moment of the
entire exchange because not only does e
la no more apparently misunderstand how
these proceedings are supposed to go she
apparently misunderstands the meanings
of the word yes and no yes sir no do you
think that massacre was a fabulous
achievement that happened under our
watch that is a ridiculous question
about yes or no no I think what know
Misso more well I'll take that as a yes
no no so miss Omar in the English
language no means no and yes means yes
perhaps this is confusing I thought by
the way the left talks about this all
the time they talk about consent they
say no means no and yes means yes but
then I guess when it comes to our
deliberative Republic no means yes yes
means no I don't know how it goes I
don't quite follow Alon Omar's creative
interpretation of our system of
government what she is referring to the
massacre is that of course when you're
looking at the politics of Latin America
very often you're you're choosing the
lesser of two Bad's to put it to put it
in a diplomatic way you've got broken
systems of government largely failed
States civil wars going on insurrections
and so regardless of which side you
choose there are going to be abuses
they're gonna be crimes that take place
Alon Omar said basically is trying to
blame Elliott Abrams for massacres that
happened under our watch is that I
didn't realize by the way that the
United States had governed Latin America
I wasn't aware of that I didn't know
that we are responsible for governing
now of course do we try to help when we
can do we try to guide the affairs of
Latin America toward the good and toward
Liberty when we can yes absolutely as as
we should we should prevent the poison
of communism but this gives this gives
moral idiots like Ilana
an opening to say well see because we
backed one side of a civil war because
we backed aside that wasn't communist
then we're responsible for every single
thing that that group ever did
okay can we hold you on Omar responsible
for everything communists ever did fun
great fine by me
killed 100 million I guess the Alon Omar
killed a hundred million people in the
20th century I didn't know that I did
but following Elon Omar's
logic that's the only thing that we
could conclude we can hold that's fine
we can hold Elliott Abrams responsible
for everything that Latin Americans
strong men have ever done so let's hold
Elano more responsible and the american
left broadly for everything that
communists have ever done fine by me i
don't think that's a game she wants to
play the idea that Elliott Abrams is a
war criminal is simply a calumny this is
simply a lie there was a good piece on
this at the Hudson Institute they
referred to by the way one of Abraham's
--is most vociferous left-wing critics
guy Rea Nayar who was then the head of
Human Rights Watch this man changed his
opinion on Elliott Abrams was once one
of his clearest critics and then later
on after the dust settled from the
iran-contra affair the politically
motivated persecution of Elliott Abrams
he came out and said Abrams his argument
that he was chosen as a target because
the special prosecutor needed a
recognizable scalp following Oliver
North's victory on appeal is buttressed
by the evidence of timing this suggests
a political prosecution rather than the
fair administration of justice they
always go back because the
administration of Ronald Reagan was so
successful they try to invent fake
controversies so one of them is the
iran-contra affair the Iran the big
iran-contra scandal which is that the
Reagan administration stopped the spread
of communism in Latin America a
wonderful thing that we should celebrate
as frequently as possible as a result of
Abrams is they just went after Abrams
because they couldn't get other people
in the administration that couldn't take
down the President so they tried to grab
any scalp that they could as a result of
all the prosecution of Elliott Abrams
the alleged war criminal do you know
what he was ultimately a sentenced to
Elliott Abrams was
sentenced to a $50 fine and two years
probation that that one gear later
immediately was pardoned by President
George Bush President George Bush who
you'll remember the left is now called a
saint
oh how wonderful he was Oh because he
died whenever Republicans die they
become Saints when they're in pert when
they're alive the left decides to try to
destroy their character but st. George
HW Bush pardoned this man immediately
because it was a ridiculous prosecution
it was a ridiculous persecution and I
think we even know this even before the
pardon because he was sentenced to
basically nothing a $50 fine in two
years probation the people who call this
man a war criminal are communists
Stooges communists apologists communist
sympathizers
the Reagan administration policy in
Latin America is not only defensible it
is correct to prevent the spread of
communism in Latin America now sometimes
that means backing strong men because
politics does not exist in the realm of
the forms or just in the realm of the
ideas it's a practical science and when
you're talking about places that are
often failed estates with civil wars and
insurrection that means that you're
going to have to you only can back bad
people or or sometimes good people who
are forced by situations into doing bad
things it's just inevitable in wars that
that this will happen no evidence
whatsoever exists that the strongmen
were worse than the Communists there is
plenty of evidence to the contrary the
attacks on Abrams
attacks like Elon Omar's are moral
idiocy at its finest and by the way I
should point out on the moral idiocy of
the law no more she is a vicious
anti-semite and you don't need I don't
throw that term around lightly I really
don't I try to not use the term racist
or sexist or anti-semite I really try to
be very careful about throwing that word
around because those words are deluded
to me nothing by the left Alon Omar is a
vicious anti-semite there's no other way
to put it you don't actually need to
take my word for it just two days ago
Nancy Pelosi her Democrat speaker in the
house Steny Hoyer the leaders the whips
that
Democrat caucus chairman the entire
leadership in Congress of the Democrat
Party condemned Delano Mars
anti-semitism in a very public statement
the other day this is not some crazy
conspiracy theory this is not some
attack from the right wing Nancy Pelosi
herself led the entire congressional
Democrat Demming Alon Omar's
anti-semitism using that word so the
mainstream media are in damage control
mode here's Jake Tapper or Jake Tapper I
don't know sometimes he's reasonable and
then sometimes he has these little
hysterical emotional fits and this is
one of them so he's trying to distract
from Alana Morris vicious anti-semitism
is on display when she begged that Allah
would open people's eyes to the evil
doings of Israel was on display when she
said that it's just Jews buying off
American politicians it's all about the
Benjamins baby that's the only reason
anybody could possibly support Israel so
Jake Tapper is trying to say that
actually Donald Trump is an anti-semite
here is because there is nothing that
this White House finds more offensive
than a politician feeding into
stereotypes about Jews and Jewish money
and controlling politicians which is
what congresswoman Omar is accused of
having done is there anybody that
doesn't renegotiate deals in this room
this room negotiator I want to really
get this Trump perhaps more than any
room I've ever spoken
maybe more okay don't write I've been
called in that a couple of times too
you're not gonna support me even though
you know I'm the best thing that could
ever happen to Israel and I'll be that
and the rear I know why you're not gonna
support man you know you're not gonna
support me because I don't want your
money
you don't want to give me money okay but
that's okay you want to control your own
politician that's fine I'm sorry that
was the wrong clip that was then
candidate Trump in front of the
Republican Jewish coalition suggesting
that haggling Jews like to control their
politicians with their money we wanted
the clip of congresswoman o mark and 12m
I want the the Omar clip give us the
Omar clip there it wait no that's not it
either that's a deleted Donald Trump
retweet from 2016 why Iowa he goes on
like that isn't he cute isn't Jake
Tapper cute now by the way first of all
Donald Trump makes a joke in the room he
says hey look I'm a negotiator just like
you guys he's making a joke that Jewish
people are good at business and
negotiating perfectly fine joke making a
joke about Jewish people negotiating is
a very different thing than praying to
Allah that Israel which has hypnotized
the world will be exposed for its evil
deeds
that's her words not my words very
different things by the way and then
Donald Trump saying to this group I'm
not going to take your money and you
can't buy me it's not like he only said
that to the Jewish group he said that to
every donor group in the GOP class that
was one of his biggest pitches for his
campaign is that I can't be bought by
donors very different and he said
actually I'm a huge supporter of Israel
very very different from Elon omar
saying the only reason that anyone's
gonna back Israel is because those
nefarious Jews are buying them off with
their money don't take my word for it
take a Nancy Pelosi's word Steny Hoyer
his word the Democrat caucus cheer all
of whom condemned her anti-semitism the
left is upset Jake Tapper is having his
little fit because anti-semitism is now
a leftist problem it's not a right-wing
problem they're very upset by this
because they know it's true it's so
obvious even Pelosi is admitting it I
wanted to get to Aziz Ansari and
Valentine's Day but you know we don't
have time we have to get to the mailbag
so head over to Daley wire.com we have
mailbag questions ten bucks a month
hundred dollars for an annual membership
you know you get everything you also get
the leftist here's tumblr this is very
important I actually pray that that God
opens up the leftist sighs so that I can
get all of my delicious leftist ears
there's actually a song talking about
carrying one's tears in a flask because
they're pleasing I'll have to bring in
the the actual psalm I don't have it
memorized people keep sending it to me
though and it's it's very beautiful nice
nice a little bit of religious whimsy go
to daily wired icon we'll be right back
with with the mailbag
all right let's get to it from James
quick comment in Tuesday's episode you
included cory booker as a woman in
saying all the declared democrats were
women and listed them and included corey
may be intentional but thought if not
you should know oh did i do that
gosh huh
from jesse dear Michael I'm sorry I
missed your appearance at Emory I would
have really liked to have gone my wife
stands attends their rather and showed a
flyer yesterday of another speaker
showing up next week that wants to make
the argument that abortion is immoral
good who apparently is a progressive
Christian who are used for reproductive
justice
kind of ironic to call killing babies
reproductive justice isn't that the
opposite of reproductive justice
I was curious to see if there was any
way to steal man abortion from a
Christian perspective or if this woman
is delusional thanks for all you do the
woman is delusional there's no no way to
justify killing babies by Christianity a
Christ is quite explicit on people who
hurt the littlest among us and what
happens to them and it's not good it
involves millstones and drowning however
there is one argument that I've heard
disingenuous Christians say John
Fugelsang
talks about this he's a left-wing actor
who says the bible defends abortion is
specifically in numbers 5 so when you're
digging into numbers 5 you know that
you're you know your arguments are not
great you're really going pretty deep
but even this argument is not true so
the way that they do this is they quote
numbers 5 numbers 5 says this if you
have gone astray though you are under
your husband's authority and if you've
defiled yourself and some man other than
your husband has lain with you then let
the priest make the woman take the oath
of the curse and say to the woman the
lord make you a curse and an oath among
your people when the lord makes your
thigh fall away and your body swell may
this water that brings the curse pass
into your bowels and make your womb
swell and your thigh fall away and they
use this as evidence that god is
instructing people to
abortions there's no evidence of this
the way they get away with it is because
there's one translation of all the
translations of the Bible there is one
that translates that phrase may your
thigh fall away as to miscarry
that's the NIV this is a notoriously
terrible translation of the Bible
there's a reason why all the other
translations don't translate it that way
obviously not a Hebrew scholar but it
seems to me I've talked to Hebrew
scholars and the Hebrew uses a
metaphoric language your thigh to rot
your thigh to fall away now does this
mean it will make the woman infertile it
seems to imply that sort of thing
but there's no textual evidence
whatsoever that the woman is already
pregnant there's no evidence whatsoever
that the dirt dust from the ground of
the temple mixed with water is some
aboard of fashioned drug it's certainly
not a surgical abortion it's it's such a
stretch but that's the one they make and
the way that you argue against that is
that they are obviously miss translating
the Hebrew there they're just rewriting
the Hebrew but that's the one argument
they'll make and and there's there is no
other argument other than other than
looking into a ship into a deep well
they look at the top and they see only
their own reflection and what they want
to see there from Brendan Michael do you
believe that the president is
responsible for the economy I'm in
college and one of my professors said
the Trump taking credit for the economy
is ridiculous what are your thoughts
thanks Brendan it's very difficult to
figure out who is exactly responsible at
any given time for the economy the
economy is a very big system
so always Democrats won't credit any
Republicans ever for helping the economy
and they'll only credit Democrats and
occasionally vice versa
however we we can credit Donald Trump
for consumer confidence and
manufacturing confidence we can
certainly credit him for that these are
people who are producing and who are
consuming who were saying that the
current policies on the economy give
them confidence in it and we have seen
manufacturing confidence at all-time
highs
consumer confidence hitting highs and so
we can certainly credit him for that now
was the economy growing before Donald
Trump took office yes has it continued
to be
really strong stronger than people
predicted stronger than under Barack
Obama yes it has can we credit Donald
Trump for that I certainly think we can
and I think it's disingenuous to say
president Trump has had no effect on the
economy when at least from the
perspective of economic confidence there
is no one else you could credit from
Graham
hi Michael what is your opinion on the
use of the Lord's name in vain
I've always refrained from using his
name in vain more especially saying oh
my god what is the idea behind using the
Lord's name in vain
is there a difference between oh my god
and for Christ sakes or Jesus thanks
best podcast on the web thank you this
is a really tough one because we use
this these phrases in our world all the
time what does it mean to use the Lord's
name in vain
if you use the Lord's name to make a
joke is that in vain I don't know it
depends on the joke I just I just did
one actually I said I I made a joke
about Alana Omar praying to Allah to
open people's eyes and I flipped that
and made a joke about praying to God to
open leftists eyes for their tears is
that taking the Lord's name in vain I
hope not I don't think so I think it's
actually making a religious point
through humor it's making a political
point as well down stream of culture and
down stream of a religion through humor
it's on the border though I'm a little
uncomfortable with it sure how about
people who just say it they stubbed
their toe and they say Oh God
that would seem certainly to be taking
the Lord's name in vain you were using
it vainly you're using the Lord's name
in a trivial manner I really try not to
do that yet we all do it sometimes
sometimes something happens you
exclaimed Jesus you probably shouldn't
do that and then the much Syria a more a
more serious rather offense is to use
the name of the Lord
blasphemously or to swear an oath to God
that you can't uphold the I mean Christ
talks about that explicitly said don't
make these oaths let your yes be yes and
your no be no that's even a more serious
offense but this is very important
because God should not be taken lightly
your creator the author of the universe
the divine love and the divine into
should not be taken lightly you should
have holy fear and humility before the
Lord that is the beginning of wisdom
as well this is why Jews don't even
write out the name of God they'll put a
- that's a it's a good spiritual
practice and I think we should all be
much more mindful of that I do my best
not to take the Lord's name in vain
I fail at it a lot you're gonna fail at
it too but it's probably best not to
from Aaron dear Michael I would like to
hear about your spiritual practices to
connect with God other than going to
church what spiritual disciplines do you
follow love the show and the glasses a
Aron he spelled it out hey Ron I read
the Bible not as much as I should but I
do I pray every night I certainly
recommend that I try to pray the rosary
though I don't do it nearly as
frequently as I should one spiritual
discipline that I find that I need a lot
and I recommend to other people is I try
my best not to complain now I will
criticize I will inve it's part of my
job is to do that but to complain about
wow wow woe is me
there was a lot of traffic I really do
my best not to do that it is a great
temptation that I have it's a great
temptation among New York Italians say
and I really try to not do that because
patients is sanctifying we should have
humility and gratitude at all times and
humility is the fear of the Lord is the
beginning of wisdom and we should
venerate and we should be grateful all
the time we're living i'm just count
your count your blessings folks we're
living at the greatest time in all of
human history we have all of the
advantages we didn't create our life we
didn't invent it it's a gift from God we
should always be grateful always all of
the time even in in mourning even in
grief we should be grateful and so that
that is a discipline that I really try
to remind myself of and you you might
have others that I maybe you have other
sins and vices that are more likely to
affect you and so you'll have a
different spiritual discipline but
that's a really practical
one that I tried to do a lot from James
hi Michael thought-experiment if you had
to choose one of the Dems to be
president who would you choose Thanks
James came for the leftist tears tumblr
stayed for the leftist years tumblr
Howard Schultz no question he's the most
reasonable led of any of the Democrats
he still wouldn't be a good president
but he there's there's no question the
difference between him and any of the
other Democrats is night and day from
Noah hey Michael how can we maintain the
teaching authority of the Magisterium in
the context of the selling of
indulgences thanks how can we defend the
Catholic Church since it's sold
indulgences first of all the Catholic
Church never sold indulgences that was
never permitted and what and what is an
indulgence people don't know what an
indulgence is an indulgence is not
buying your way into heaven it's not
buying time out of purgatory it's not
buying your spot before the biotivia
vision and indulgence is a remission
before god of the temporal punishment
due to sins whose guilt has already been
forgiven the temporal punishment due to
sins not getting into heaven faster or
at all there's no selling now one of the
ways to get there you can still get
indulgences obviously it's but there was
never selling where it got complicated
were abuses and corruption crept in were
that you could receive an indulgence for
alms giving giving to the poor giving to
a charitable organization you can see
how this would be rife with corruption
and there was there was plenty of
indulgences roms giving before the
corruption crept in
but then the corruption crept in this is
what Martin Luther used as his excuse to
to rewrite a Christian orthodoxy and at
the Council of Trent in 1567 all of the
grants of indulgences involving money
were canceled because of a recognition
that abuse has crept in so I think it's
easily defensible you just have to
defend it based on the facts of what
actually happened the history and not
the anti-catholic legends that have
crept up over time I'll take one more
before we go from Katherine hi Michael
my younger brother is in college right
now and like you and his early teen
preteen years he became an atheist he's
quite conserved
minded otherwise do you have any advice
for me besides praying for his
conversion Thank You Katie
yes appeal to his intellect appeal
probably really to his intellectual
pride I give him logical arguments for
God show him Aquinas is arguments or and
some of Canterbury's arguments or give
him books written by intellectuals like
CS Lewis or Chesterton do this because
the one of the reasons that precocious
thirteen year olds become atheists is
they get all of this soft soap silly
emotivist religion and they think that
there's no intellectual warring and then
people such as Christopher Hitchens who
are clever come in and they have
intellectual confidence and pride and so
they they are more likely to follow
those people if that's what happened to
your brother then beyond praying for him
what you should do you should try to use
that intellectual pride and twist it and
use it to gods advantage and ultimately
to his own advantage and bring him back
alright that's our show we got a lot
more questions but too late happy
Valentine's Day I hope you all enjoy it
on your Boeing brand sheets and purple
mattresses you know and well I hope you
always enjoy your bone and brain sheets
and purple mattresses I have a very good
Valentine's Day in the meantime I will
see you next week
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19